eight news now breaking news alert
thank you very much for joining us here
at noon i'm john langley we do begin
with some breaking news on saturday's
car crash which killed nine people today
the clark county coroner identified the
final victim tananga miller from north
las vegas
the crash happened on cheyenne near
commerce street north las vegas police
say two men were driving more than 100
miles an hour on commerce when the
driver failed to stop at a red light and
drove into traffic
in all six cars and 15 people were
involved and again nine were killed for
the families of the victims the grief is
fresh they say they are fed up with
speeders on the all across the valley
tamika henry's cousin tiffany may
survive the crash but she was injured
and she's now recovering in a hospital
it is absolutely disgusting that in this
day and age that people choose
to disobey laws disobey
just again the regard for life life is
precious
henry says her cousin has a long road of
healing still ahead
our eye 8 news now i-team is also
digging into the driver police say is
responsible you see on your screen there
his name is gary dean robinson he died
in the crash he had a long criminal
history dating back to the 1980s he and
the passenger in his vehicle that dodge
were both killed in the collision